danny duffy who makes back-to-back
starts against the white sox danny
pitched to a no decision friday at
chicago and tim anderson the lead off
for chicago tim anderson's really been
tough on danny duffy anderson is 12 for
35 that figures out to a 343 average and
that pitch grounded back up toward the
middle that's going to sneak into center
field for a basic good start
that's tim anderson grounds one right up
the middle lead off man is the board and
that'll bring up eloy
grounded and cut off by franco and the
royals are going to turn a double play
the pitcher's best friend cleans the
base pass and now yazmati grand all will
bat with nobody on and two outs hit into
right center field that is going to get
down for a base hit second hit of the
game but unfortunately after the double
play one man on here for jose abreu it's
out over the plate
but hit off the end of the bat
and olivares is there so two hits with a
big double play and one left dylan sees
on for his eighth start an even three
era probably a few too many walks as far
as he's concerned and left-handers
right-handers doesn't matter he handles
them both well but he's given up a lot
of home runs whit is over his last 12.
fastball from c shot to center and
robert one goal that'll bring up hunter
dozier let the velocity of the pitch
provide the power all you got to do is
just put a nice easy swing on it that's
well hit luis robert is on the move but
that ball is gonna land in and out of a
seat in left center field and hunter
dozier
has a trolley wire home run and the
royals take a one-nothing lead in the
first inning edwin ankaracion will lead
it off this is a right-handed heavy
lineup there's a ton of power so it
would follow that lefties would struggle
with this lineup
oh did he ever that ball could end up
across the state line where tied at one
man
i love when he hits one like that
everybody's doing the parrot catch the
fever 1-1 bases are loaded for the sox
on hit number five the first time
through yeah they're really blasting
away at duffy yet they only have one
runs it's imperative that tim who
usually hits duffy well drives at least
one home up and out ball four run comes
home the white sox take a lead two to
one still the base is loaded eloy
jimenez at the plate and jimenez really
helps out duffy and we mentioned he's
slumping at the moment he's down on
strikes for route number two two out for
us monty grandall kind of get the
feeling this is a really big batter in
this game oh way outside bouncing off
the glove and here comes mendic it is
3-1 socks when they invented the call
wild pitch they had this one in mind
it's ball four duffy cannot harness
his command right now three walks in the
inning newberry still getting loose and
abreu's coming next you're really
rolling the dice here jose could very
easily with one swing make it one too
many jose in the air left center field
up the alley way and off the wall
one is home here's the second rondo
follows and he is out at the plate
sox pressed it a little bit abreu gets
himself a two run double
and it is five to one that'll go back to
the top of the order now for tim
anderson who drew a walk with the bases
loaded to driving a run in that five run
second inning tim goes upstairs to swat
this ball to right center field and it
is gone
tim runs it up and out of here that ball
carried and carried and carried and it's
now six to one white sox here in the
fourth inning but now runners will be at
the corners first and third with only
one out and the batter is monteci hits
one in the air on the first pitch sky
high pop of into short right field adam
engel going out so is tim anderson he'll
spin and make the catch and then fire it
back in toward the infield that's out
number two there's cam gallagher runners
out of first and third for the royals
here with two outs in the fourth and
that's on the ground left side on
cottawood field off balanced throw to
first going to be in time nice job there
by montana and the inning has come to an
end dylan sees strands and that is a
double for michael franco here's alex
gordon swung on hit pretty well right
center field robert racing for it he
dives can't make the play franco will
score to second base as gort and the
royals cut the chicago lead to six to
two and here comes ricky renteria 96
pitches for dylan cease
and that's going to be it for him and
here comes matt foster runners at the
corners and nobody out and that'll bring
up nikki lopez rips it down the right
field line that's a fair ball it's a
double and two rbis for nikki lopez and
all of a sudden we've got ourselves a
close ball game it's six to four and two
down with a runner at third now back to
the top for wood merryfield now
merrifield skies that one in the air to
right center field
tracking that one though is luis robert
plenty of room out there in right center
field and the inning has come to an end
first and third for the white sox here
with nobody out at the top of the
seventh here is jose abreus driven in a
couple extended his hitting streak to 17
straight hit to the right side and
through base hit hilo jimenez will score
jose abreu's got himself another run
batted in it's now 8-4 white sox here is
luis robert well this is where luis
wants to be he's got a pitcher who's not
hitting his spots oh boy there it is
way out of here oh
staircase shot bring him home
there's that hanging slider on a t
that young man has unbelievable power
just now 11-4 white sox here in the
seventh inning so the young center
fielder edward oliveiras stands as the
last chance here for the royals
here on this thursday night 11-6 white
sox bottom nine though the royals do
have the bases loaded up the middle
danny at second turns it loose and got
him they're gonna take another look at
him
it's close now the call on the field is
out so they would need indisputable
video evidence to overturn
oh wow i think he's safe at first what
is the call will this game continue
no it's over sox win
wow
what a finish to this ball game